por segundo año consecutivo el
movimiento feminista en Madrid sale a
las calles dividido en dos
manifestaciones distintas por un lado
está la de la comisión 8m trans
inclusiva y mucho más multitudinaria que
la otra este año 2023 es el primero en
el que marchan por las calles de Madrid
con una ley trans aprobada y en vigor
da histórica con todas estas personas
que han visto vulneradas
sistemáticamente
y queremos decir también que sigan
quedando muchas cuestiones
de derechos para todas las mujeres
todavía necesitan derechos aunque ya ha
pasado mucho tiempo y ahora tenemos más
pero tenemos que seguir manifestándonos
yo creo que En definitiva el espíritu
que reina de toda la gente que venimos
aquí es de compartir el mensaje y el
motivo por el que estamos aquí no que es
8 m el Día Internacional de la mujer
aquí estamos la feministas por otro lado
marcha el movimiento feminista de Madrid
que se autoconsidera abolicionista de la
prostitución y entre otras cosas fide la
dimisión de la ministra de igualdad
española Irene Montero Porque tanto la
ley trans que
ha hecho el Ministerio de igualdad como
también lo del sí solo sí tienen
defectos de forma y de fondo muy
importantes y que vulneran los derechos
de las mujeres y estaba perjudicar a las
leyes de igualdad a las de violencia de
género a las cuotas paritarias y se
presupone que no va a haber
fraude por parte de los hombres pero yo
digo ya conocemos como son este 8 de
marzo llega a España Un día después de
que el gobierno aprobará la ley de
paridad por la que cualquier órgano de
decisión tanto económico como político
tenga por ley a partir de 2024 que estar
formado en un 40% por mujeres